[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss welcome to another
episode of the tim ferriss show my guest
today is michael sure sure
depending on who you ask on twitter at
ken tremendous we're going to ask about
that mike michael created the critically
acclaimed nbc comedy the good place and
co-created parks and recreation brooklyn
nine-nine and the peacock series
rutherford falls he is also an executive
producer on hbo max's hacks and
netflix's master of none prior to parks
michael spent four years as a writer
producer on the emmy award-winning nbc
hit the office
his first tv writing job was at saturday
night live where he spent seven seasons
including three as the producer of
weekend update with tina fey and jimmy
fallon his new book is how to be perfect
subtitle the correct answer to every
moral question
michael welcome to the show thanks for
being here thank you so much i'm very
excited to be here
i thought we would start with something
we chatted about just a little bit
before pressing record and that is the
harvard lampoon i have this fascination
with the harvard lampoon and i would
just love to perhaps offer you the mic
to introduce the harvard lampoon to
people and also describe how you entered
the fray
how you actually became part of the
harvard lampoon the lampoon is this uh
very old institution at harvard it was
founded in i think 1876
and it is this weird
satirical comedy magazine
that has just been kind of plugging
along for now almost 150 years and
there's a couple interesting things
about it one of them is that the alumni
are
numerous and
very high achieving like it william
randolph hearst was in the lampoon and
so was john updike and so was george
plimpton and
a million comedy writers in the in
from like the 80s to the present who
have written for you know letterman and
the simpsons and and snl and all these
shows conan o'brien was the president of
the harvard lampoon twice which is a
very rare thing so
it's just this kind of weird little
humor outlet
that people who are obsessed with comedy
kind of learn about at an early age
i learned about it from
just noticing that it kept popping up
when you would see certain movies that
you thought were funny or
like doug kenny wrote animal house and
and um and he was on the lampoon and jim
downey who is a legendary comedy writer
at letterman i think he was letterman's
first write head writer and wrote
so many of your favorite snl sketches
throughout history he was on the harvard
lampoon so when i applied to college
i that was like on my essay for harvard
was i i want to come here because i want
to join the lampoon so when i got there
that was like goal number one for me was
joining it and you there's like an
audition process you have to write
material and then you get the pool of
people gets windowed down and then they
accept a few writers every semester i
have to imagine
by the time you got there certainly
it was thought of almost as a feeder
into
these
careers in comedy and therefore
there had to be
quite a wide funnel in terms of people
interested in becoming part of the
lampoon they can't accept everyone what
did the audition process
look like what constituted the audition
process the lampoon is a pure to the
extent that it could be
uh was a pure meritocracy it was there
were artists writers and there were
there were business people who sold ads
and if you were trying to get on as a
business person it was like did you sell
enough ads if you did you got on if you
didn't you didn't if you were an artist
you drew a bunch of pieces
you were critiqued and and sort of given
notes by the other artists on the staff
then they voted on what their favorite
artists were same with with writing you
wrote three pieces
uh comedy pieces of the subjects were up
to you
you were winnowed down
from the total number of people trying
to get on to you know half that and a
half again and then they would bring you
know six to eight people to the election
and then vote however many that they
wanted they would vote on
this was part of the sales pitch was
that it was a meritocracy
so i decided to
kind of test that theory because i was
skeptical
so i submitted my pieces
the first time i tried out
i submitted anonymously or to the extent
i could i
i only wrote my my first and second
initial so they didn't know whether i
was male or female they didn't know
really who i was at all and i i got
admitted i made it past the first cut
and i should they have a like a cocktail
party for people who make it past the
cuts and i showed up and they were like
oh you're that guy like they was like oh
welcome congratulations and i was like
wow they really really was anonymous
like they didn't know who i was didn't
care
they just were like are these things
funny or are they not funny
so then you did that again you submitted
three more pieces
you had got notes there was another
round of cuts and then there were
elections and you just waited in your
room
for the full day not having any idea
what was going on and then they would
show up and say yes or no
and if the answer is yes and then you
got bread brought into this kind of
week-long
semi not really hazing it's kind of a
parody of like a of like a frat hazing
week
but you spend a week like getting
indoctrinated into the world of the
lampoon and then you're a member and
everything is great the
writing pieces and this is rewinding the
clock so i recognize that this is asking
a lot but
do you have any recollection with that
paradox of choice situation where the
topics are up to you
how you chose what you would
write about are there any constraints
like 500 words or less thousand words or
less is there
there were i wish i remember they they
they put a page limit on them you know
because it's prose comedy it's a kind of
comedy writing that isn't done that much
anymore like the closest analog that
people might be familiar with is
something like the shouts and murmurs
page in the new yorker like a lot of
lampoon people have gone on to write
shouts and murderous pieces for the new
yorker pro's comedy used to be much more
common you know like magazines used to
have the
humor you know pj o'rourke wrote humor
for rolling stone and right people would
write humorous pieces for the new yorker
or for for any number of different
magazines it doesn't really exist
anymore like many things involving print
media
but i mean i remember the only one i
remember offhand is i wrote a piece
speaking of the new yorker
that was the premise was it was like a
series of increasingly angry letters
being written to you by the new yorker
because you hadn't re-upped your
subscription yet because at the time i
had been given i've been gifted a
subscription as a freshman in college
by someone probably my dad who thought
like well you're in you're uh you're a
college man now you ought to read an
intellectual magazine
and and then it lapsed and i started
getting these like really angry letters
that were like
you know like what's the deal what how
could you have betrayed us like this so
you legitimately were getting these in
indignant letters from the new yorker
i was and they kept offering me like the
free tote bag if you re-upped and i i
remember just continuously thinking like
i don't want your damn tote bag man like
leave me alone
so
i wrote a piece that was like you know
five or six in a series of like letters
asking you to re-up that it just got
increasingly antagonistic and aggressive
so it was that sort of thing and like
that would fit on one page you know what
i mean like that's 500 words or 600
words or something
and you know brevity is the soul of wit
and so if your piece was too long they
would often hack it down and tell you to
make it shorter and stuff
so they weren't they wasn't like you
know
you're not talking about 20 page long
humorous short stories these are like
short little bursts these are shouts and
murmurs level bursts of of humor i don't
i wish i i'm sure somewhere in a box
somewhere in my house is my original
pieces that i submitted but but they're
at least for my memory they're long gone
uh
oh sorry go ahead i was just gonna say
that that is one of the great things
about comedy as a discipline is that you
know stand-ups will tell you that the
reason they like being stand-ups
frequently is because
there's a vote right like you write a
joke and you perform it and the audience
votes immediately whether or not that
joke is funny and it's not quite as
immediate
in tv or movies or some other forms of
comedy but there is a sense of like
you don't know whether
you have gotten it right
and then you get a reaction from people
that's visceral
that that sort of says like you're on
the right path or you're not or you kind
of are but you could
you know you can spruce it up a little
bit like that's what made saturday night
live so great was like you would do we
would do a dress rehearsal at eight on
saturdays and there would be a live
audience and you'd run the sketch and
then some jokes would work and some
wouldn't
and then it would end at 10 and the show
goes live at 11 30.
so you would there this this thing would
occur to you which is i could either
leave it alone do nothing
and get exactly probably the same
reaction that i got the first time or i
can try to fix this i can cut this joke
that didn't work i can try to write a
better punch line like there was an
immediacy to it that was weirdly
comforting because
it what sometimes you make things in
like months and months and months go by
and then they sort of float out into the
universe
comedy very frequently especially comedy
for performance is just
peop it's like a roman coliseum you know
a bunch of people gives you a thumbs up
or a thumbs down and then it's up to you
to figure out what to do next so
i really like that about comedy in
general like there's not a lot of you
can certainly write jokes
that don't work that you still believe
in and you can cling to them if you want
to but you also know like no one's ever
gonna laugh at this and if you're okay
with that that's fine you can leave it
in your movie or your show
but you at least have the information
that you were looking for very quickly
let's talk about snl for a moment i was
going to ask you about lessons learned
at snl but there are a number of
different ways i could frame the
question another would be
how do you think you would be different
had you not had the snl experience as a
comedy writer
producer
fill in the blank i'm just curious
because i think i have read
somewhere and i'm paraphrasing here that
you you think everyone or any comedy
writer should sort of do a tour of duty
if possible
at snl for a period of time
i'm sure a lot of more people would like
to than ken but what were some of the
lessons learned from for lack of a
better way to phrase it
so many
i do believe that by the way i think
that if everyone who worked in hollywood
had to work for one year at snl
in general things would be a lot better
so
from a creative standpoint
the thing that snl teaches you is
to not be precious with your own
material you generally have about four
minutes to do whatever you're gonna do
right like with rare exceptions
you're talking about four minutes and so
you write a sketch
and it's five minutes and 38 seconds
long
and
you go in with a red pen
and you just make giant x's on your
script like cut this cut this cut this
this didn't work change this and and
after doing that every week
for you know seven years
there's almost no joke or piece of
writing that i could put into a script
that i would think that cannot be cut
like it just trains you to say anything
can be cut and
if it improves what you're doing then
cut it and i think that's a really hard
lesson
for some people to learn especially when
depending on where those people where
people come from what their backgrounds
are
if if you grow up in a system
i mean creatively grow up in a system
that doesn't train you not to be
precious with your own material and then
you achieve any kind of success
you are
almost always way too precious about
your material because you have this
sort of personal belief that you you did
this alone it's you know you know you
figured it out you cracked the code and
how dare anybody tell me to cut this or
cut that or how dare the these
executives think that this is too long
and as a result
you know you can look around right now
uh on your streaming service of choice
and you can find a lot of
shows and movies where you think to
yourself that was about 25 minutes too
long like that i liked it it was good
but man why was that so long and the
answer is almost always like they just
didn't get tough enough on their own
material yeah so snl is just ruthless
about that it just doesn't snl is like a
lauren michaels has many aphorisms that
he likes to
dole out to you and as you sit at his
feet and he dispenses his wisdom
but one of the things he has been saying
for i think about 50 years is
the show doesn't go on because it's
ready the show goes on because it's 11
30 on saturday night
and that ethos sort of permeates
everything and it reinforces this idea
that like you just you work on it and
work on it and work on it until it's
done and then you're done
but
you know
the level of success you have with any
individual sketches a little bit
up to whether or not
it's it's based on whether or not you
are tough enough on your own material so
that's a great lesson that's a really
really wonderful lesson for a writer of
any kind to learn
another thing it teaches you and by the
way i should note if you meet and work
with anyone who went through the snl
gauntlet of fire
everybody has that same
that same sort of attitude toward their
own material
so
when you're talking about an actor like
andy sandberg so my friend dan goran had
created brooklyn nine-nine andy sandberg
we got andy sandberg to star in it andy
sandberg was a very well-known and
beloved comedian
and was pretty famous on his own right
thanks to his own work
and
yet when we would show him cuts of
brooklyn episodes in the early days he
would go like i'm bad in the scene cut
me out of this cut this cut my joke here
it doesn't work cut this cut this it's a
very rare star of a tv show
who will say cut my material you know
like that's not the typical attitude for
like number one on the call sheets star
of the show guy on the poster usually
those people are like wait i want more i
want more put me in this more put my
face on tv more people who went through
snl
judge
comedy and material based on only like
is this good is it funny does it work is
it fast is it quick is it enjoyable
that's a wonderful trait in a producer
actor amy poehler's the same exact way
like the so everybody who goes through
this system has this
sense of like it's not about me it's
about the end product and if the end
product is made better by removing me or
removing scenes i'm in
or lines that i have or jokes that i
have then remove them like because
that's the we we all win if this thing
is better
so
there are other ways you can learn those
lessons snl is just a particularly blunt
force trauma way to do it it's a very
like it's a very intense kind of like
like sledgehammer to the head over and
over again that kind of drills this idea
into you
so i'm gonna
return to
the the end of your snl tenure but
before we get there i wanted to ask
about i'm not going to say the
antithesis because i don't think that's
totally accurate but
perhaps a contrast in styles or at least
someone who is not purely encapsulated
by
brevity is the soul of wit and that is
david foster wallace
it seems like you have a long-standing
fascination with
david foster wallace how did that start
why is that the case
there's a extremely long-winded version
of this story i'll try to i'll try to
make it only slightly long-winded this
isn't morning tv so we can go as long as
you want
so
february of 1996 i am at the end of my
junior year in college and infinite just
comes out and uh my friend rebecca says
to me hey have you heard about this book
everybody really likes this book
uh we should go buy it we went to the
harvard bookstore and we both bought a
copy of the book
i read the book i started reading it
that night and i didn't stop until i was
done
it really something about it just
altered my brain chemistry and changed
the way that i thought about
literature and writing and the world
it just it's one of those things
everybody has a story like this about
some piece of literature right it just
it clicked like you i heard an audible
click in my brain
as i was reading it and
i was looking for a senior thesis topic
for my senior year and i went to my
advisor and i said this book literally
just came out
like this month
and i know that you want that like what
i'm supposed to do is pick like a dh
lawrence novel or a henry james novel or
some other or you know
billy budd or something but i just kind
of want to write about this and to his
credit he was like sure go ahead like
it's your thesis you write about what
you want
so i ended up spending an entire year
then
writing about the book and thinking
about it in terms of like how it fit
into the post-modernism canon
and
around
um i can't remember now maybe october of
the following year wallace came
he was on a tour and he announced that
he was coming or maybe he was that
spring i think it was that spring he
announced he was a book tour and he was
coming to the brattle theater which was
in cambridge
so i was president of the lampoon at the
time and one of the things the lampoon
does is it gives out awards to people
like there's a
there's a and it's always sort of a joke
right there's like uh they one year the
hasty pudding is the old
famous 18th century social club at
harvard and they give out a man and
woman of the year award and it's always
you know literally like tom hanks and
julia roberts or whatever it's like the
most famous people of the world and they
all come so the lampoon would do a
parody of that and they would say our
man of the year is randy macho man
savage so and then we would have randy
macham and savage come and give him a
big fancy dinner and present him with a
giant trophy and whatever
so
we used to have the you know celebrity
dinners from time to time so
unilaterally without even asking anyone
else who worked at the organization i
decided that david foster wallace was
going to get an award from the harvard
lampoon
which i titled uh i think novelist of
the millennium or something
i'm just a college junior and i called
his agent and said like hey
i'm gonna level with you like we're
making this up we we're just completely
making this up this award but like it's
a really cool building and it's a fun
group of people and he's gonna be in
town and if he if he wants to come we
would love to host him for a dinner
so i was working on my thesis about a
week later my phone rang and i picked it
up and said hello and the person said
hey this is dave wallace is this mike
shore
and it was just wallace calling me on
the phone and he wanted to know since so
like my heart is pounding like i
it was very surreal and he was like look
i he had gone to amherst and he knew
about he knew what the lampoon was
he was at amherst in the early 80s and
he said like it sounds really fun to
come there but like i'm very i'm very
sort of like press shy
and you know i don't i don't want a
whole big hullabaloo and i was like
listen man we're just making this up
like we just want to have you come hang
out with us if you want to come hang out
with us we don't have to do any kind of
public ceremony or whatever just come
and hang we'll show you the building i
think you'll really dig it
so he did his reading we brought him
back to the castle and we just had a big
dinner with him with the whole staff and
by then
a bunch of people on the staff had read
the book and really loved it and we just
hung out with him and he was great and
we we had an amazing conversation i have
a picture on my wall i'm staring at her
right now
of me lighting a cigarette for him which
is like
if my house is if my house is burning
down like
and i have only time to grab five
objects from my house that's one of the
ones i'm grabbing
so that began
a correspondence between the two of us
he was an excellent
corresponder
he wrote letters to
hundreds and hundreds of people
frequently when you would get a letter
from him it was like a half of a piece
of paper that he had just torn off from
a you know
it was like a jagged edge and he would
just scribble a note and say like
checking in seeing how you're doing or
whatever he was at illinois state
teaching english and we corresponded for
a while and i tried to get him to come
to snl
to see the show because he was obsessed
with television and i thought it would
be really fun for him but he was too shy
and he never made it
he eventually moved to california and
taught at pomona and we sort of lost
touch and
i kept it thinking in my head because i
moved to california like oh i should
reach out to him now that i'm out here
and i never did and then tragically his
his mental health problems caught up to
him and he he committed suicide
and it's one of those sort of like great
tragedies in my own personal life that i
didn't more aggressively pursue i mean
he had he had a a million correspondence
uh i think i i've when you read stories
about him you'll often read like
a lot of people have the story of like i
wrote him a letter out of nowhere and he
wrote me back and we corresponded for
five years like it was a thing he did
so i don't think i'm special in any way
but i really do regret not sort of
trying to rekindle our little
epistolary friendship when i moved out
to california
so
long story only slightly longer um at
some point i had the thought that like
it would be really a really interesting
writing challenge to adapt infinite jest
into
not a movie because that's impossible
and not an ongoing tv show because
that's also impossible but some kind of
limited series
and this is years ago now this is
probably 12 years ago
at the time
a thing that's very commonplace now
which is a sort of
you know like mayor of east town was
like this like a sort of six or seven
hour mini series
that has like a very high budget and
stuff like that that didn't really exist
back then
but i tried to convince people
that it would be a really good book to
adapt into something like that and i was
and i i had optioned the rights to it i
had sort of gone to his estate and made
my case as like a guy who could be
trusted with this
book which is so important to people in
my generation
and they had given me the rights to it
and i sort of tried to get people
interested in it and it was sort of
taking off a little bit
and it looked like it might happen
and then for a number of reasons it just
kind of didn't happen
among them that his the people who
control his estate became
just kind of generally wary of hollywood
for a number of reasons and kind of
didn't really want there to be a lot of
adaptations of his material
and i was like well i don't want to do
anything that would ever make any of you
feel uncomfortable or or make you feel
ill at ease so
i just sort of backed away i let the
option lapse and that was sort of the
end of my involvement but there was a
brief moment in time back in 2000 i'm
going to say 2008 910 somewhere around
there
where i was like i think i'm going to
spend the next like four years of my
life trying to adapt this enormous
ridiculous book into a you know an
eight-hour mini-series it would have
been a very there's a sliding doors
thing where like that could have been
the way my professional career went
have you ever thought
or would you ever resurrect
that
goal to adapt in some fashion infinite
chest have you read the book i hesitate
to ask i haven't i'm not gonna lie i
have not i've read a bunch of his
writing mostly shorter stuff sure string
theory and a lot of the shorter stories
but infinite jest i it was
just too intimidated by the sheer
magnitude for the bulk of it just the
bulk of it yeah i won't say that i would
never consider it again because if you
ask me what my favorite book is it's
probably the answer like that's probably
my favorite book i've ever read
there's a problem with adapting it now
which is that the book was so it came
out in 96 he wrote it you know over the
call it eight years prior
and the book imagines a very near future
um it is it's almost it's almost a
little black mirrory if you've seen that
show where he's imagining it take it
takes place in
so it came out in 96 and it basically
takes place from like 2000 to 2008 or so
and he's he's projecting forward and
extrapolating into what he saw going on
in society and imagining the kind of
slightly warped slightly fun house
mirror version of what the world is
going to be like
now of course we're 20 years past the
date when he was imagining it and so in
order to do it and in order to honor the
book properly you would sort of have to
do your own version of what he did which
is look at the world now
and project forward from here and you
also would have to be as good at that as
he was which is saying something because
among other things in that book
he basically predicted like facetime and
video messaging like literally what you
and i are doing right now he there's a
whole section in the book about that the
president of the united states is a
celebrity who's obsessed with germs
and is uh kind of a [ __ ] who doesn't
really understand the way anything works
but it doesn't matter because he's
really popular like there's all these
kind of he he called his shots and a lot
of them kind of came true
and you'd have to be as good a sort of
fictional futurist as he was in order to
do a good job and i don't know that i am
or that anybody is really so
i'll never say never but it would be it
would be even tougher to do it now than
it would have been then
that's a tough assignment yeah that
would be
that would be very very tough not
impossible but tough for the reasons
that you mentioned you know as you're
as you were describing
the challenge i was i was thinking of
motherless brooklyn and what edward
norton did with that
and his
obviously his colleagues and everyone
else did with that novel because they
had some creative challenges
with respect to how
the characters although if it's set in a
somewhat contemporary landscape within
the novel
speak like
old-timey gangsters
to one another
and so they they had to make a lot of
changes with the film adaptation which i
thought worked really really well but
i'm way deep in the uh
ignorance pool on this one i'm this is
way beyond my pay grade so let me flee
the landscape of david foster wallace
and go back to the end of snl how did
you choose what you would do
after that and how did you choose the
timing if if you chose it i don't know
i didn't really choose it it kind of
chose me because i was dating a woman
who is now my wife
who had moved to la
years before and we had been long
distance
and
it had gotten to the point where it was
sort of like well if this is going to
work either i have to move to la or she
had to move to new york and it made a
lot more sense for me to move to la
because that's where all the jobs were
so i had been at snl for
at the time i'd made the choice i'd been
there for about five and a half years
and i had this realization which was snl
is a little bit of a i guess you call
like a golden handcuffs kind of a
situation
because
normally when you work on a tv show
even in the best of times you're hyper
aware of the fact that this is going to
end right like at some point the show
will end and you will need to find a new
job
snl
unique among television shows in the
last five decades never ends it just
goes on forever so the situation is
you're working in new york
you make a very good living
you have a really cool job that anyone
that you meet when they find out what
you do wants to talk to you and hang out
with you right
and it could never end you could just
kind of do it forever and so i basically
gave my 20s to that show i started when
i just turned 22 and i worked there
until i was 29
and i left in part because i realized
that if i didn't
achieve escape velocity
i might just stay there forever and
that's not the worst thing in the world
right like it's not a it's you only work
like half the year because you have all
these weeks off and make a good living
and i i bought an apartment in manhattan
when i was 25 like that it was a it's
kind of an amazing life
but i just had this sense that if i
wanted to do more creatively
i had to leave and so all of these
things kind of lined up like my feeling
like i had sort of
gone as far as i could go or that i
wanted to go really my then girlfriend
now wife living 3 000 miles away the end
of my 20s like all of those things kind
of coalesced and i just decided okay
this is going to be my last year
so
halfway through that year i went to la
for the first time professionally
and started
meeting executives and taking these
general meetings which are all identical
you're having like it's really crazy
making like you have six identical
meetings a day you go into
a room
and you're meeting with the vice
president of comedy at fox and the
assistant says would you like anything
to drink water diet coke and you say no
thank you and you go in and you meet the
senior vice president of comedy at fox
and you chat amiably for 50 minutes
almost to the minute it's 50 minutes
long and then you leave and you get back
in your car
and you drive somewhere else and you go
to another waiting room and now you're
meeting with the senior vice president
of comedy at 20th century fox and you're
like wait these are different places yes
one of them is a network and one of them
is a studio and you go into a room and
the person says would you like a water
or a diet coke and you chat amy blee
with this new person for 50 minutes and
it just keeps going and going and going
and you write samples you write i wrote
a curb your enthusiasm spec script and i
think that was it actually at the time
and so if those people like your samples
they'll send them to their the people
who have new shows coming on the air or
the existing shows looking for writers
and you'll go on a hundred more meetings
with those people well i'm i'm so and so
i created it i wrote this pilot called
welcome to happy and it's a sitcom about
six people who are friends and they live
in chicago and and you watch their pilot
and then they go i really loved your
script and you say thank you so much
your pilot's so good and then you chat
amiably for exactly 50 minutes and then
you get back in your car then you drive
across town to some other person and
it's this kind of like endless
just uh treadmill of meetings meetings
meetings meetings so out of that giant
morass of meetings
there were a couple people
who really liked my sample and had an
opening
a couple of them were new shows
one of them was an existing show but the
guy who was the most interested in me
was greg daniels who was adapting the
office from the british show from the
british version to the american version
so i loved the office i the british
office it was my i found it to be
maybe the greatest comedy that had ever
been made i thought it was a work of
pure genius and i thought that the idea
of adapting it for america was
incredibly stupid and foolhardy and
would never work in a million years
uh nonetheless i took the meeting
with greg
and
he instead of like going to a place and
having the hanging then go in here in 50
minutes and then you leave he and i
talked for about two and a half hours
he was immediately
much more
kind of specific and also much more
interested in going in depth about many
more things than anybody else had been
he wanted to know all about
how i wrote my script why i did certain
things within the script
he wanted to know about my wife had
written for another show called coupling
that was an adaptation of a british
sitcom that hadn't worked and he asked
me a million questions about it why did
i think it didn't work
what was it about the adaptation that
fell short
at one point in the middle of the
meeting he said i have a bad back would
you mind if i lay down on the floor
i said no go ahead and so he just lay
down on the floor in front of me and
the whole thing was just like after
after 50 identical meetings boom boom
boom boom boom with 50 different people
at in every level of hollywood
that meeting was special and interesting
and weird and captivating and i left
that meeting and i sent my agent an
email and it said i don't know if that
guy's gonna offer me a job but if he
does i'm gonna take it because i think
he's gonna
teach me how to write like i just get
the sense that he's like a professor
and he knows how to do this he he's like
uh he sees the matrix code
behind stories and i think he could
teach me how to write
so he offered me the job and i took it
and that's exactly what happened he
taught me
that absolutely in a in a
collegiate professorial kind of a way
how to write stories what makes them
good what makes them bad what makes
character work good or bad like
plot and and motivation and and
character all the stuff that you need
he taught a class he taught a phd level
class
and i soaked it all up and it's what
it's the greatest stroke of good fortune
that's ever befallen me i would say is
falling into greg daniels's world
i have so many questions about
your time with greg it's hard for me to
even pick a place to begin
so the
the first
thing
that i'll ask which is probably the
easier question to answer is
when you sent that email to your agent
did you still think the show was not
going to work but you didn't care
because you're going to get an education
or did you come out convinced that it
had a chance of working it's a good
question in the email which my agent
still sends back to me every once in a
while as a reminder of like the
beginning of this journey i believe i
said something like i don't know if the
show is going to work but if it doesn't
work
it won't be because of that guy like the
reason won't be that the guy in charge
doesn't know what he's doing like if it
doesn't work it doesn't work but
there's no one
that gives it a better chance of working
than greg daniels and i i had that
instinct
after that one meeting i just kind of
knew from the way he was talking about
it and approaching it
that if there was a hail mary's chance
of this actually succeeding
that it he was the quarterback who was
gonna throw the ball so
i don't know that i was immediately like
oh wait i was wrong this is a great idea
to adapt the office i don't think i got
that far but i definitely felt like he
was approaching it from a completely
different angle than i would have ever
imagined anyone would approach it and i
was right he did and that's why it
worked
what did you at that point recognizing
that's and i'm going to use the wrong
terminology so i apologize but that skit
comedy is very different from what
he was aiming to do
what did you feel that you were missing
in terms of skill set
or
that you most wanted to learn from him
oh i was missing everything the answer
is everything because
so sketches are
single ideas single comedic premises
executed as quickly as possible
and then you have one big joke at the
end and you get out that's all it is
right it's a it's a it's an observation
about the world or a comedic premise
that you
introduce to the audience develop as
quickly as you can
milk it for all it's worth and then it's
a tissue you throw in the garbage you
you pluck it out of the box you blow
your nose and you throw it in the
garbage and it's over and you don't have
to worry about anything else you don't
have to worry about what happens to
these characters tomorrow who cares
tomorrow's sunday there's no show right
so
so long-form tv writing is a completely
different animal the thing that snl can
teach you
potentially that is relevant is just how
to be funny like how what's funny what
are funny
ways of observing the world or things
you've noticed about people or ways to
write jokes craft language that sort of
thing
but long-form tv writing is you're
establishing characters and and you're
slow cooking them over hopefully
in the office's case 200 episodes right
you don't these are not tissues anymore
these are like carefully
honed in crafted doll houses with like
miniature furniture in them that all
need to be properly sanded and painted
and like placed in these really specific
ways
and you have to keep coming back to them
and you're building them you're building
this dollhouse slowly piece by piece
brick by brick over the course of
a decade when it works right so
all of that stuff was new all of the
whole idea of saying like how how do you
pace out a character growth over
multiple episodes multiple seasons how
do you establish
interesting relationships and dynamics
that you can go back to over and over
again like
what are the deep
veins that you're when you're mining the
ore like how how can you tap into the
deepest possible vein so that there's
the most material there
all of that stuff was brand new and
completely unknown to me and by the way
to most people who were on the writing
staff and so that was what he was
teaching us what he was teaching us was
was
this is not about being funny like jokes
are easy if you get a bunch of funny
people in a room and you say hey this is
a scene where michael scott is leading a
diversity seminar and he doesn't have
any idea how to run a diversity seminar
you get eight comedy writers in a room
they'll come up with a bunch of funny
jokes
what's important is why is he doing that
what is the like character trait that's
led him to be the kind of person who
thinks he has the ability to run a
diversities training seminar when he
definitely doesn't what are the
circumstances under which he
would
try to pull this off in front of
documentary cameras that are there
documenting his every move like why is
he looking at the camera here why what's
going on in jim's life that he's in love
with this receptionist named pam and
she's engaged to this guy named roy who
he hates how does that fit in like all
of those
layers
and sort of like
all that grist for the mill that was
unknown to me i and it was what greg was
so good at sort of imparting was this is
the stuff you have to care about now
it's not about making a funny joke and
then
getting out and you know letting the
audience clap and then like throw to the
musical guest so they can perform song
like that's snl this is not snl this is
an entirely new animal
all right so i'm going to
follow up on the the professor
i've read in uh
i think it was an interview
of sorts profile and vanity fair this is
from 2008
that
one of the mission statements or the
mission statement for the office could
have been let's make sure they're all
changing right speaking to that
character development that you mentioned
you can't be too fast it can't be
overnight it
has to not necessarily mirror reality
but
it's one possible
mission statement and
what i would be curious to know
and if there's a better way of phrasing
this question feel free to answer a
different question but let's just say
that the professor were actually
teaching a phd class or a seminar
what do you think
he would lay out in the first
class or a few weeks of class are there
any other lessons an alternate question
would be can you tell a story about a
specific instance
a teaching moment that you recall while
being at the office
oh god um
yeah this is this is a real how much
time you got kind of a deal because i
could tell you a thousand i got as much
time as you'd like
okay so i'll answer both of the
questions which are different the day
one stuff the phd level class
day one in the same way that a professor
of newtonian physics would say
would write f equals m a on the board
and then everyone would scribble it down
in their
in their notebooks or type i guess and
this is how it's showing you how old i
am that i'm still imagining people
taking notes with a pen i still scribble
there you go
so the f equals m.a of sitcom writing is
stuff like okay here's what matters in
stories right what matters is
characters motivations for doing what
they do
the plots having good twists and turns
in them because comedy is all about
thwarting expectation and if people see
something coming then they'll they won't
laugh
being
surprising escalation is another big one
right if if you see a story where the
same thing happens two scenes in a row
you get bored so whatever happens in the
second scene has to be bigger and more
intense than what happened in the first
one
there are certain things that i think
you would establish as f equals m a type
rules that you would then
undermine right like you would say
there's a there's a certain quality that
executives like to refer to as
likability
which is a kind of a reductive term but
it essentially means that if people if
audiences don't in some way identify
with characters they don't like those
characters and
that doesn't mean in the world we're in
now and this has been true probably
since roughly speaking the sopranos came
on board and suddenly the main character
of the biggest show on tv was a
sociopathic mobster who killed people
regularly
you wouldn't call it strictly speaking
likability but you might call it
relatability you might say the main
characters on a show or that have to
have some aspect of them that people can
see in themselves or at least identify
with or say i have a cousin who's like
that or something like that those are
the amino acids right that's like the
basic folding blocks yeah as far as
teaching moments
as many aphorisms as lauren michaels had
about
comedy greg has just as many
and
i'll give you one example so i wrote an
episode of the office in the second
season that was about it was a christmas
episode and it was an episode where they
were doing a secret santa so they'd each
draw on a name and they had you know
this person is buying a little gift for
this person and this person's buying a
little gift for this person or whatever
and the premise which was really funny
was that michael didn't like his gift
right so michael's gift came from a
character named phyllis on the show and
she had knitted him some oven mitts
and he just didn't like them he didn't
think they were a big enough gift and he
and he had gotten
he had drawn ryan ryan was the temp
played by bj novak he had drawn ryan in
the
secret santa gift exchange draw and he
had bought ryan a video ipod
so even though it's a classic michael
scott thing because there was a 25 limit
or whatever and he because his he was so
desperate to be loved just bought this
kid a 400 video ipod so he gave a video
ipod to his person and then he got for
his gift a woven oven mitt and just lost
his mind and so he changed it
from a secret santa to a yankee swap
which is where you can swap your gift
for any of the other gifts it's another
gift right because he wanted to unload
the oven mitts and get something better
so
when i wrote the episode i did this
thing where i
i was like okay well the reality i've
been a part of many secret santas in
many offices and i i know how you do it
you do a draw so i put all the
characters names into a hat and i did a
real draw i said like okay oscar is
drawing now and i picked out and it was
creed okay oscar's gonna buy a griff for
creed so i did it the way it would
really be done
and
there was a one of the characters had
angela angelo is a character on the show
who
was very uptight and fairly religious
and
she
was very prim she didn't like to
curse she didn't do anything that was
sort of like she was just very very
uptight
and so i had in the script that someone
bought for her
a sort of
vaguely christian kind of self-help book
that was sort of like you know it was
like seven habits for following in the
light of god or something like that it
was just like a sort of one of those one
of those books that are perfectly lovely
and helpful for people who are looking
for some guidance in their lives and who
are religious
and it didn't factor into the plot at
all it was just a detail of the script
that that's what she got
and greg was like
no we should come up with something else
and i was kind of confused cause i was
like it's not even a joke we don't even
make a joke about it it's just literally
like she opens the gift and
and then that's what it is
but he was like yeah here's the thing
though we already know that angela is
religious and we already know that she
is the kind of person who would buy a
book like that or would like a book like
that
and what would be better is if there was
something that were like
overlapping in the overlapping area of
the venn diagram of what we already know
about her
and what we can learn about her that
would broaden her
character right that would make her into
a more interesting person dimensionalize
her a little bit
and so what we came up with was
that she loved
those kind of photographs that people
take where they where babies are dressed
like adults you know that you know
there's like a weird corner of the
photography world where it's like a baby
but dressed like a jazz musician with
like a
like a fedora and like a toy saxophone
and somehow i don't know why but somehow
that was like that's perfect like that
is exactly the kind of thing that she
would like may i interrupt for a second
yeah how the hell does that come out of
the ether did it just pop into someone's
head i mean yeah how did it land there i
can tell you definitively that i did not
pitch it because i believe i was
completely unaware of this phenomenon
but that's why you have a room full of
funny people because you just say okay
here's the character here's the subject
matter
pitch on what she would like pitch on
some aspect of the culture and some i
wish i remember too someone pitched that
and immediately was like oh my god
that's perfe i don't know why but that's
perfect so
so we changed it to someone got her this
poster of two babies dressed like jazz
musicians
and
again it didn't factor into the episode
in any meaningful way but that poster
was then added to the set she put it up
next to her later in the season we
designed an entire episode over the fact
that another person who sat near her
hated it so much that there was like an
hr complaint lodged against her
and
and it like it flowered it just bloomed
into this thing that
lasted for
years and years and years and so
greg's thing and this is what that
vanity fair article is referencing was
like at the end of every episode of the
show you should have at least a little
bit more information about some of the
characters than you did before the
episode started and it doesn't have to
be a huge thing it doesn't have to be
like my dad was you know arrested as a
serial murderer or something it doesn't
have to be some gigantic thing it just
has to be a little bit
more than what you knew before and as
long as that's the case the show
continues to be more interesting and
kind of grow and expand
that was a
fantastic example thank you
that was great all right so i am going
to ask you about
the pitch for the good place right how
it was pitched before we get there
though
i want to come back to
i don't want to say a throwaway comment
but a passing comment that you made
which was you know if i could only take
five things from my house
as it were burning down and you
mentioned
the photograph of you lighting a
cigarette for david foster wallace what
are some of the other things that would
be on that short list
okay so i played this game a lot with
myself
here are the rules of the game if you
want to play with me the rules are
your family and your pets are safe so
you don't have to worry one of those
objects doesn't have to be a human being
or an animal right
and you assume that nothing in the house
is going to be
salvageable after you remove these five
objects so it's not you can't hedge your
bet you can't say
i'm gonna take these things and then
hope that this other stuff survives
you're saying like
this is it the house is burning to the
ground you get five things right so
uh okay so i'm not actually sure
that photograph is probably top five but
i also have a copy of infinite jest that
wallace inscribed to me when i met him
that is probably if i had to choose
that's probably the one i would take
uh i might take both of them that would
be maybe that's too much david foster
wallace
but i i think i would take that book i
also i'm a book collector i collect
first editions
so among the the rarest book i have is i
have a first edition copy of moby dick
that is in incredibly good shape it's
really really a rare
copy of that book because obviously back
then
no one really cared about paper quality
or acidic paper or anything else this
copy happens to be extremely bright and
crisp i would probably save that just
because i feel like
that would be cruel to let them to let
that burn up in a fire
most of the objects in fact the only
real objects that i care about i think
are probably books
there's a writer named david halberstam
who is a sports writer who is um
he was a friend of my wife's family
and he was a red sox fan i'm a red sox
fan and in christmas of 2003
he inscribed a copy of one of his books
to me with a long message about how he
really thought 2004 was going to be the
year
the red sox had just gotten
keith folk a relief pitcher and kurt
schilling as starting pitcher who would
they might put them over the top and
they just lost a heartbreaking playoff
series to the yankees and he wrote this
thing that was like i really think this
could be the year
and then it was like 2004 is the year
they won the world series for the first
time in 86 years it would be awfully
hard not to rescue that piece of
piece of literature from my house
so the answer is when i play this game
is usually five books oh i'll tell you
there's one thing that isn't a book that
i would save which is after the good
place ended i got a call from my agent
that said where are you
i need to send you something i was like
just send it to my house and he was like
no it has to be hand delivered
i was like all right what is it he was
like i don't want to tell you what it is
just just wait
so
a messenger came to my office and handed
me an envelope and it was a
handwritten note from president barack
obama
saying that he had watched the good
place and really liked it
and it was so like the the cognitive
dissonance i guess you would call it of
receiving that object and opening it and
reading it in his own hand
was so
like my i my hand started shaking
because i thought this is like i
shouldn't be holding i should be wearing
gloves or something in order to read
this
and it's incredibly meaningful to me and
i framed that letter that letter is also
on my wall underneath the picture of
david foster wallace smoking a cigarette
is it on
white house letterhead or is this i have
a jagged edge is it from like a
restaurant
place it's the back of a denny's menu
yeah
yeah i wish that would make it even
better
i wish it were i wish it were on i wish
he had done the maze on the front of the
denny's menu and then on the back it
just written off dashed off a note to me
that would be amazing
how did your
book collecting of first edition start
we're not gonna don't worry i'm not
gonna spend an hour here although i
could but how did that begin like what
was the
beginning of the collection where you're
like oh oh this is this is now a thing
for me
so my uncle steve who now lives in
ireland was a book collector and he sort
of introduced me to it when i was a
teenager
and
i've always been a collector of things
when i was a kid my my dad's former
college roommate for my fifth birthday
bought me a bunch of baseball cards
and to this day i can recall the sense
memory of like opening the plastic
around it they were what were used to be
called rack packs where there were like
sort of three sections of cards
and i remember ripping them open i
remember holding the cards in my hand
and flipping through them and like the
tactile sensation of that is like
incredibly
drilled into my memory
and i became obsessed with them and i
bought i spent all my money on baseball
cards and and plastic sheets to put them
in and i organized them and i collected
full sets and later when cds came out
like the feeling of buying cds and
holding them and opening like it was
it's almost fetishistic in the way that
i think of like those collections like i
just loved it i just loved that feeling
of like building a collection of
something
so i was i'm clearly predisposed to this
but my uncle bought me a couple
first editions of books that i liked
and you know when you collect books you
get
incredibly fussy about they can't be in
direct sunlight and the humidity and the
room has to be at the right level and
they it's all this kind of ridiculous
hobby stuff
but one of the things you do is you take
the book cover off and you put it in
this plastic sort of mylar
stuff to keep it from getting spilled on
or keeping dust off it or whatever and
the the feeling of that plastic in my
hands like and the sheen the sort of
like shininess that it made the book
look like
i mean it's literally no different than
what what libraries do right it's the
library it's that plastic that goes
around the covers of library books
again something just kind of like lit up
it hit some pleasure center in my brain
and i started becoming a completist
where i would say okay
i have a first edition copy of
penin by vladimir nabakov because i
really love that book but now i have to
get all of his books so so like
the flight you need the whole thing i
got to get all of them and so there were
certain authors that i just started
collecting
and i just would wouldn't be truly happy
until i had gotten first editions of all
of their books and
for a while i was doing this with no
money we did not have a lot of money
growing up at all and i had i took on
like most people in this country i took
on an enormous amount of student debt
and yet it didn't slow me down at all
like i was still like any money i had
for my for my student jobs it was going
right to like used in rare book stores
and i was scouring in the early early
days of the internet i was scouring ebay
for
obscure copies of dondelillo novels that
someone might not know the value of and
stuff
so it just it started from that it just
was like a thing that my uncle did that
who got me into it and it's continued
it's only burning brighter
as i age and
now actually make money so i can it's
dangerous i have enough money to spend
on these things now and
it's not slowing down if you're
wondering
man i would love to see your library
sometime that's uh for i know this is
just a first date so i'm getting ahead
of myself but in any case
we are going to get to
the pitch for the good place i promise
but you've mentioned a number of things
that i have to pick up on and you can
make this as long or as short as you
like you mentioned sports writing
can you please explain ken tremendous
sure um the explanation is not
super interesting i was in college
and i was walking home from somewhere
and
the i i'm obsessed with uh crazy names
always have been like i loved monty
python growing up and one of the best
things about monty python is that all of
the
characters in their sketches have
bananas names and i i loved loved loved
crazy names
so
i think i was again this was like
something got rewired in my brain at a
fairly early age but i was walking home
and the name ken tremendous popped into
my head as a funny name to use in
something i didn't know what it was just
like that's a funny name because ken is
kind of a normal boring straightforward
name
and then putting the word tremendous
after it just made me laugh
so i just i went back to my dorm and i
jotted the words ken tremendous down on
a piece of paper i thought maybe there
was a short story or a comedy piece for
the lampoon or something where i would
use that name
later when the internet sort of
really began to
you know be the place where everybody
spent their time
and
avatars and and handles online handles
became a way for people to cloak
themselves
i thought well
i don't i this scares me the internet
scares me it's it's dicey i don't really
want anyone to like track me or know who
i am
so i'm gonna just could do everything i
do on here anonymously and i chose ken
tremendous as my sort of internet name
so
when i used to run a blog with a couple
of my friends but there was a sports
blog called fire joe morgan that was us
complaining about bad sports writing and
bad announcing
on that blog i was ken tremendous when i
when twitter started i was like i don't
know what this is but i don't want to i
don't want it to be me so i'll make it
ken tremendous and just everything i do
online
just became ken tremendous
and what's
endlessly funny to me is that first of
all i know long ago stopped trying to
hide the fact that that's me like every
like if you google ken tremendous my
picture shows up like it's not like i'm
trying to pretend to be anonymous
but
about two or three years i think into
being on twitter as ken tremendous
they sent me one of those notices that's
like we'd like to verify you
and i was like but it's a fake name what
do you mean verify me like that's
ridiculous and i was like do you know i
wrote back like on the dm
the thing i was like you know that this
isn't my real name and they're like yep
don't worry we're verifying you and i
was like okay so i'm verified on twitter
as an imaginary fictional personality
it's kind of amazing oh that is amazing
ken tremendous it's a good name right it
is when i was doing some original
research
before we even booked this and uh
found i found you as ken tremendous on
twitter i was like is this possibly
accurate
you just never know because on one hand
it could be
and you know i love these stories i know
a number of people are pretty well known
but they have these ridiculous handles
because they in the beginning a might
have had concerns about security or
privacy or b they were like twitter this
is never going to be anything right so
then that's how you end up with like
angela merkel's like hot fuzz 487 or
whatever i'm making that up that's not a
real example but and you're like how the
hell does that happen
so
i have to ask about tremendous it is a
very weird aspect of my life but it is
funny
it is very funny to have an alternate
personality
like the the back story for ken
tremendous for some reason is that he's
a pension plan monitor at a made-up
company called fremulon insurance
wait a second do i know that word for
some reason why do i know fremulon
fremulon became my production company's
name right and evolved by shows there's
a graphic for an imaginary company
called fremulon
it's a it's a whole there's a whole
other metaverse thing going on where
there's a there's a company called
fremulon and a guy named ken tremendous
working at it
oh this is fantastic it's so good you
mentioned
the five things in the house you take
with you you're like this is a game i
play quite often with myself yeah is
that an exaggeration or is that true and
if it's true why
is that a game that you play with
yourself so often no it is true and i
think it's because
i'm not a particularly materialistic
guy
i'm not bragging about that i'm just
sort of stating a fact i i don't i don't
have a lot of things
that i care about like i'm not like a
a wrist watch guy or a clothes guy or
or a you know a car guy like i i just
for whatever reason i've never
like i never i literally never wash my
car never unless i unless it's so dirty
i can't see through the windshield and
it feels like a potential death trap
like i just because i don't care and i
just think like it's a box that gets me
from point a to point b and i don't care
what it looks like and if they get
dented i don't care like i
the thought of like spending money on
car upkeep is bananas to me and and that
i don't
hold it against people who do care
honestly like if that's your thing
that's your thing great more power to
you
but because i don't i have a lot of
objects i care about when an object
enters my life
that i do care about it it gives me a
sort of moment's pause or like a an
opportunity to kind of reflect on
what i have that matters and what that
means about me at a different age like
when i was 25 what were the five things
that mattered to me what how is that
different from 35 or 45 like it is
weirdly a game i play a lot with myself
and i think it's
i've never really thought about why but
i would guess that it's like a way for
me to kind of check in
on my life to see like what is what's in
my surroundings that that has value to
me or that matters to me and why does it
have value to me or matter to me at that
moment you know
yeah
i do
sounds like i need to play this five
things game more frequently with myself
i wish i had done it
and recorded it though
over time that would actually yeah
really provide
a lens
yeah like if you could go back and say
like here's my list every year and that
would be a more certainly a more
effective way of achieving what i'm
what i'm hoping it's achieving which is
like to give you some kind of pattern in
your life or to sort of give you some
kind of path you can follow of like
here's where i came from here's where i
am now yeah
well let's let's talk about one place
you were now i'm not going to go play by
play through the
entire chronology of course because i i
i think that people can do plenty of
their own research on that but the
the good place and the pitch how did you
how did you pitch that i mean did you
basically have carte blanche to do
whatever you wanted and therefore
you didn't really have to pitch or
how did it come to be and for those
people who do not subscribe to my
newsletter
i am a huge fan of the good place wrote
about it
my newsletter five bullet friday which
went out to a few million people long
long long ago
and it was a real trojan horse for me
because
it was recommended to me as a funny show
and that was it and that's how i got
started then i was like wait a second
here
this is a trojan horse for all sorts of
stuff that i would not expect
immanuel kant didn't see that coming so
what was the pitch
when parks and recreation ended
brooklyn nine-nine was still on the air
but parks and rec ended and
the people running nbc sort of said to
me like we'd like you to do a new show
and you can kind of do whatever you want
it was one of those deals and we will
guarantee
13 episode season now
even today
the business has changed so much that
that's far more commonplace today than
it was at the time at the time
that was a very exciting kind of oh my
god like they're not gonna make me do a
pilot and then look at the pilot and
then determine whether they're gonna put
it on the air and then order
a small number of them and maybe cancel
it after five if the ratings aren't good
like
all of the sort of pitfalls of a new
show were at least temporarily removed
so
when they made that offer which was very
kind of them
i
had a thought which was like man i kind
of owe it
to
the
like myself and i kind of owe it to like
the idea of being a creative force on
television to try something insane
you know like i had been doing something
essentially the same at that point for a
decade which was writing stories about
a
group of people in a place on earth like
the office was a group of people in an
office in scranton pennsylvania the
parks and rec was a group of people who
worked at a at a government office in
indiana and brooklyn nine-nine
was a group of people who were police
officers and detectives in new york city
and it was like those shows were so fun
and great but they were
within the same general umbrella and i
sort of thought like man i i could do it
again i could come up with
a group of people who were working on
the international space station or a
group of people who work at an ice cream
parlor in belize but
it would be it feels like i've been
given this opportunity and i ought to
take a kind of crazy swing so
they really wanted a family show i had
never done a family show
and so i being a good rule following
soldier
i i put a lot of thought into like what
would it look like for me to do a family
show and the truth is
there's not that much that's very
interesting about my family like i'm
from i'm like a
i'm a sort of
middle-class white guy who grew up in
like a suburb of hartford connecticut
and
there is
there's a lot that's been said about
people like me on television and my
family on television and so
i kind of like
i had this idea i had the nascent idea
for the good place rattling around in my
head and had for a couple years like
it's in little tiny pieces
this idea had been kind of like bugging
me
and so
i thought about that and i started it
excited and i developed it on my own
time
and
it just became very obvious like that
was the interesting idea and
of the many many rules of creation
or of writing that have been taught to
me over the years by a number of very
smart people
the the best and most
trustworthy
is
write what's interesting like don't try
to don't fake it like if you have to
fake it if you have to try to tell
people that your idea is interesting
then
then you're dead right so like this it
just seemed like the best idea i had and
the most interesting and then that
presented a number of challenges like
for example how do you sell a tv network
on the idea of doing a show that's
explicitly about moral philosophy like
that's a tough sell and so
question number one what is moral
philosophy right
yeah
yeah
yeah and how do you and how does it work
on tuesday at 8 30 on nbc right so i did
a couple things to try to make it
palatable
to my bosses one of them was i worked
way harder and for way longer developing
the idea than i think i would have
normally
if i were writing a show about six
goofballs in an office somewhere in
pennsylvania
although pause for a second to say that
greg worked for an entire year on
developing the office before he ever met
with me or any of the other writers like
he put an enormous amount of work into
that show
but
my point is that i worked harder on
figuring out what the story was for the
entire season because they'd given me an
entire season to work with
then i think that i would have normally
i had the entire season mapped out
before i pitched it the second thing i
did is i talked to ted danson and
kristen bell
who i wanted to play the main parts and
they had expressed interest in playing
those parts so when i went in to pitch
the show
i said here's the show and i laid it out
for them i told them what the pilot
would be i told them what the themes
would be i told them
what what the general arc of the entire
first season would be i was and i said
to them
i've been working on this for a long
time if you have a lot of questions i
promise i'll have answers for you like
there's no aspect of this that i haven't
thought about
i also told him that ted danson and
kristen bell were at least in theory
interested in being in the show which
helped a great deal because once you
have ted danson and kristen bell in your
show they don't care what it's about
like be about anything like those are
two big stars right and the last thing i
did and i think the most important thing
i did was i said listen this is a show
about what it means to be a good person
and
the
engine for this the mechanism
is the study of moral philosophy
and that's not going to be like shoved
into the margins
it's not going to be like a casual
reference here and there it's going to
be the the guts of the show it's going
to be in every episode of the show one
of the characters is a moral philosophy
professor who is going to be like
teaching people stuff
and
and i know that that might seem
like a risky idea but i promise you it
will not feel like homework it's going
to be funny and it's going to be
entertaining and i think that moral
philosophy
has
in a way that no one maybe would think
at first glance is actually a very funny
discipline to me it's like the thought
experiments are really funny and the
people who invented these theories are
really weird and funny
so i said i promise it won't feel like
homework now that being said the third
episode literally begins with the
character chidi standing at a blackboard
with philosophy 101 written on it and i
was like bubbly like maybe i spoke too
soon
but that was how i not only convinced
them to let me do it but also tried to
reassure them that i wasn't going to
bore people to tears that i was like i i
know
this is a show about moral philosophy
but i also fundamentally understand that
it's a half hour sitcom on a major
network that needs to have jokes and
funny stories and plots
that are entertaining and
i kind of just asked them to trust me
and and they did and it was really cool
of them that they let me kind of take
this wild idea and run with it
you are very good at taking these
thought exercises right or these
problems that philosophers are
attempting to tackle
and
divorcing them from the
i'm so serious kind of
pedantic
vocabulary
that can just be so problematic and the
language that usually accompanies it
which is just impenetrable in some cases
and i really appreciated the the trolley
problem episode sure which people should
check out
you mentioned that the idea or some
semblance of the
show was kind of percolating in some
fashion for some time why was that
i think because it's a subject that's
that interested in me
before i even really understood that it
was a subject like the the concept of
making ethical choices or trying to make
better ethical choices than the ones you
made or coming into
contact with ethical dilemmas and then
wrestling with them that was something
that i always found really interesting
there was an event that happened in my
life where my wife
bumped into a guy going about one mile
an hour in traffic
and
there was a cop there they were both
rubbernecking or at least my wife was
rubbernecking at another accident that
had happened next to them
and so there was already a cop there so
he saw that there had been this little
chunk and he came over and he looked
everything over and he says i don't see
any damage here and my wife and this guy
exchanged numbers and went on their way
and then we got a bill in the mail
for
836 dollars i think because the guy said
his fender needed to be replaced
and i kind of lost my mind a little bit
because again i'm a dude who doesn't
care about cars and i found this to be
ridiculous and overly
fastidious and sort of car culture just
annoyed me
also
it was literally the day of hurricane
katrina
almost destroying new orleans and i had
friends who lived in new orleans and i
loved new orleans my wife and i had gone
there on a vacation
fairly recently but for like before that
had happened and and
it was just one of these moments where i
just kind of i just lost my mind and
i said to the guy uh i went and looked
at his car and if if if you shined a
flashlight on it
you could see
that there was a little sort of
l-shaped like not even dent like a like
a mark like a little tiny indentation i
think that my wife's
license plate holder had just kind of
pressed into his fender a tiny bit
and you could barely make it out
and i said you know what this is not 836
of damage i know that that's what it
costs to replace a fender but like this
is ridiculous and this is why car
insurance rates are so high and and and
uh how about this i said i'll donate 836
to the red cross
and we call it even
and the guy was like i kind of want my
car repaired man and i was like well
that's my offer what do you take
think it over tell me tell me what you
want me to do
and so
i went back to work i was at the office
i went back to work and i told everyone
the story and then they started getting
angry and being like that's that's so
obnoxious like how can this guy do that
and then other people started going i'll
add a hundred bucks tell him it'll be
936 dollars to the red cross and then
people started piling on another 200
another 50 another 20 whatever
so then i was like wait there's
something here you know so i i started
like a blog basically
and i said like how much money will you
donate to the red cross for the katrina
relief fund if this dude decides not to
fix the bumper on his car
and
it it like exploded and it went to five
thousand dollars and it went to ten
thousand then it went to twenty thousand
and i just and it started circulating
and i started getting press requests
from like good morning america and npr
in these places
and my wife and i were like this is
amazing like we're gonna save new
orleans all by ourselves like we're
we're gonna do it you know
and then
all of a sudden like one night line like
the second night or the third night
we were talking about everything that
was going on and we suddenly both got
like sick to our stomachs
and we're like
we feel bad and we don't know why what
there's something wrong with this this
is bad
oh my god this is bad but we didn't know
why
and
i was like i need someone to tell me why
what i'm doing is bad because i'm pretty
sure it's bad
so i went on the internet and i looked
up a bunch of philosophers who taught
ethics and i called them on the phone
and was like will you talk to me i'm
just this guy
here's what happened will you talk to me
about what i'm doing
and they all said yes because it turns
out philosophers love talking about
philosophy like they're so they're so
excited to talk about philosophy at any
hour of any day
so they sort of in different ways walked
me through a bunch of arguments as to
why what i was doing was
bad and by the way some of them didn't
think it was bad some of them thought
like look there's
aristotle writes about shame and the
importance of shame and if you feel no
shame you have no sense of disgrace and
like what you're doing is essentially
shaming this guy into what you see as a
better value system than the one he
currently has
and i was like okay
but also shaming people doesn't sound
like a great way to spend your time and
they're like well no it's not great just
shame people like this or whatever and
so i just ended up having like a dozen
conversations
about this i talked about it to every i
was so annoying i was like i've never
been more annoying in my life because
this is all i could talk about we went
to a wedding my wife and i went to a
wedding and we sat next to this guy i
had gone to college with who i knew was
very smart and i was like hey give me
your take on this and i told him the
story and he was like i'm outraged and i
was like i know right he was like no i'm
outraged on his behalf you're being an
[ __ ] and i was like oh no
and so
i couldn't get over the idea that there
was a right answer
that was my both my main mistake and the
the sort of beginnings of this kind of
now what's now a lifelong interest in
the subject is i was like well there's
got to be a right answer and what i
eventually realized is no there's no
right answer there's a bunch of theories
that will say here's why what you're
doing is a little bad or a little good
or more good than bad or
whatever but there's no one you're not
going to like suddenly turn a page in a
book read something and and be
completely satisfied that everything
is answerable like this is a complicated
weird
confusing situation
so the effect that this had on me
was to kind of coalesce
years and years and years of
what i would call a a
amateurish interest in the subject right
like it was a thing that i would like
read an article about some ethical
dilemma and be like oh that's
interesting i'm interested in this or
something would happen in my friend
group or or with my family and i would
sort of a little like sense would
something would flitter around in my
brain and i would think like this is a
subject i'm interested in but it was
very very casual and then that incident
with this minor car accident and the way
that i pursued trying to get to the
bottom of what was right or wrong about
it kind of clicked in something clicked
into gear and then it became
it became a thing that i thought about
all the time and that i really cared
about and was sort of at the center of
my life and so
that was that's all the backstory for
how the show came about
but it really is i can trace the show to
that event and and i and that event was
in 2005 and the show started in 2015. so
it was at least 10 years of kind of prep
in in some way or shape or form
to get me ready to write the show
it's a very important question
what did you do at the end of the day
with respect to the bumper great
question
so
after talking to i talked to a lot of
professors and professional types and
the last guy i talked to said
listen
i don't even really think this is a
philosophical question
i think what i would say is you're kind
of being a jerk to this guy and you
shouldn't be a jerk to people
those are the exact he used the word
jerk which was a great old-timey word
did you call this guy out by name or did
you leave him
anonymous no as i write about in the
book i made a couple good decisions
amongst many bad ones and among the good
ones i made were i never named him i
never showed a picture of his license
plate i never like
sent you know you didn't dox him on the
internet before doxing was a thing i
didn't dox him right yeah so
that conversation with that particular
professor made me think like yeah like
this guy has no idea any of this is
going on
there's something fundamentally unfair
about that and so i called him up
the way it had been left a mere like
three or four days earlier when i had
gone to see his car was because all this
happened so quickly so three or four
days earlier it was like here's my offer
i'll donate this money to the red cross
and he was like let me think it over
and we just sort of made vague plans to
talk again
soon so like three or four days later i
think i called him and was like hey
buddy
let me explain
what has happened and i told him the
whole story i told him everything i was
like i'm gonna come completely clean to
you i told him everything that had
happened
and i apologized profusely because i
what i really realized is that the thing
i was engaging in that made it so unfair
was
what most people today would call what
aboutism right like he was saying hey
your wife bumped into my car and i need
to replace the fender and i was saying
yeah but what about hurricane katrina
and it's like all right yeah like i
hurricane katrina is terrible it doesn't
have anything to do with the fact that
your wife bumped into my fender right
so
i basically said like i'm really sorry
this was not fair of me to do i had cut
him a check and it was in the mail i
said like their check is in the mail and
he said
okay thank you and maybe i'll make a
donation maybe i'll give part of it to
the red cross and i was like great i
hope you do but you're under no
obligation to do that like
nice doing business with you and that
was the last time we ever spoke and
so
it was just a really fascinating weird
little moment
that kind of for whatever reason ignited
this thing in me that was like i think
this i i think what it made me realize
importantly and this really is what led
to the book and the show
was the idea that like these things
happen all the time like that is
obviously a fairly extreme example but
we're constantly milling around and
bumping into people and having kind of
interactions that where one person feels
slighted or wronged in some way somebody
cuts in front of them accidentally at
the line at the grocery store or
pulls into a parking spot when another
person was about to pull into the
parking spot or whatever
these little mundane interactions that
we have with other people
have i realized
significant ethical dilemmas to them
very frequently and our choice becomes
am i going to care about that or not
like
i could not care about it right i could
just say like whatever i you could
forget about it the moment it happens
move on with your life never think about
it again
but i felt like because i went through
that
that there i couldn't shake the idea
both that there are ethical components
to almost everything that happens and
that we are better off when we pay
attention to them and really try to
untangle them and wrestle with them and
so
that was really the you know 10 years
before the show was pitched and written
was really the beginning of this journey
for me was coming to the realization
that ethics matters that i think that
it's important that ethics matters and
that you
kind of try to get to the bottom of
these things when they pop up
so how to be perfect
right so you have how to be perfect
subtitle the correct answer to every
moral question which is uh tantalizing
to say the least
uh
how did you decide to do a book right i
mean i think that most people think of
you as a writer but they would think of
you as a tv guy
and
books are
writing certainly and one would hope but
they are a different animal
why why do a book
and i should just preface my preface
by saying
i read somewhere i don't know for for
research for this conversation
a line of sorts that i just i just loved
and so i'd love to
hear you expand on it which is you would
love the book to do for moral philosophy
what a brief history of time did for
astrophysics
i think something along those lines
which is a hell of a goal so
mike is yours wherever you'd like to go
what i meant by that and i was being a
little facetious because i think that
book sold like 38 million copies or
something so i don't want to
it was tongue-in-cheek but what i meant
by it and continue to believe is that
that book which i read when i was i
think in high school
took this subject that most people would
say
there's no way in hell i am ever going
to engage with that subject i am not
going to spend my free time
my precious free time
reading a book on astrophysics about
black holes and singularities and event
horizons and
no way no way i won't understand it and
it's pointless right
and yet
he had a way of making all of that stuff
both entertaining
and also fascinating without being
condescending like that was what's
really remarkable about that book is
that he does not condescend to you he
says at the beginning of the book that
he's not going to include any
mathematical formulas because his editor
told him that every mathematical formula
he included in the book will reduce his
audience by 50
so he's like all right there's only one
mathematical formula it's equals mc
squared i promise that's the only math
but it wasn't like in a condescending
way he was just saying like look i get
it this is weird and hard but
i think it's fascinating i've devoted my
life to thinking about it and i feel
like you can get something out of this
and then he talked to you like you were
a grown-up he talked to you like you
were an adult with a brain and
i set out as my that is my goal because
i feel
after spending so much time wrestling
with this stuff again in a amateurish
way i'm not a professional i'm not an
academic i don't have a phd i didn't
really even study this stuff in college
i just read a lot of it talked about it
a lot with a lot of people
i think that it's the kind of subject
like astrophysics
that people would think like no way i'm
not doing this like i don't i'm not
gonna understand it it's pointless to
even try
and when i was reading it i had this
thought that i couldn't escape and the
thought was
these are the smartest people who ever
lived right like generally speaking
they're among the smartest people who
ever lived aristotle and kant
and uh and locke and hobbes and jeremy
bentham and david hume and all of these
people
you would put them in the
top millionth of one percent of all of
humanity who have ever lived in terms of
just brain power right
and they spent their lives or at least
parts of their lives
trying to figure out how we could be
better people that was their goal that
was like what is right what is wrong
what's good what's bad how do we improve
ourselves how do we make the process of
being alive on earth
as maximally good
as they can be
and yet they wrote their books
so
densely and opaquely and at times
impenetrably and boringly that no one
wants to read them unless you're like a
philosophy major in college like i
remember thinking
it's like someone wrote a recipe
for a chocolate chip cookie that's both
delicious and helps you lose weight and
build muscle mass
but the recipe is 600 pages long and
it's written in german and no one's ever
reading it and if you could somehow
take what they wrote synthesize it and
talk about it conversationally
with people
in a way that isn't condescending but is
engaging
that might be of use to people like
people might enjoy that and so
it was a little bit the reason i wrote
the book was that feeling mixed with a
feeling a personal feeling of when the
show ended
simply that i wasn't quite done talking
about this stuff yet i just felt like i
wanted to talk about it a little more
and the show was over and it's like i
wouldn't know what to do so i sort of
said like well what if i write a book
that sort of summarizes all of the stuff
that i feel like i learned
as i wrote the show
and that's where we ended up
have you done any long form really long
form writing
between
thesis
about
david foster wallace and the book no i
have not okay wow yeah i have not for
you i haven't written anything
longer than a feature film script since
1996.
well that speaks to how
important you think it is and i'm going
to push back just a little bit
in a sense and that is you are
not a professional philosopher and i
don't say what i'm about to say to
insult any philosophers i've had some on
the podcast but there is no bar exam for
philosophers right and i think that you
are
there's a quote that i wrote down which
i think you've
invoked at points from david foster
wallace novels are about what it means
to be a [ __ ] human being right yeah
and i think moral philosophy in a sense
also
could be described along those lines and
you
seem to me to be a
student of
humans human nature relatability
character character development so i it
strikes me that
you
seem very qualified actually
to write
such a book
it's kind of you to say and and to a
degree i think you're right in the sense
that i think that anyone who spends a
lot of time thinking about
the human condition
and whose job
is to actively observe it interpret it
discuss it write about it engage with it
which is what the job of being a tv
writer really is
you know
being a tv writer if you are lucky
enough to be on a show that lasts for a
long time
you have spent
seven years eight years
125 150 individual episodes with the
same characters and you have
done that thing that greg taught me to
do which is slowly expand their
their personality profiles and their
worlds and their
their sets of motivations and you've
tracked them over big life events of you
know sometimes getting married or having
children or changing jobs or whatever
and it does i think
first of all you're drawing from real
lives of real people you know or real
feelings that you and other people you
know have had or you're imbuing the
characters with those feelings
but you also at the at the end of the
line
you really have this sense of like i
kind of get that character i know that
character really well now i've studied
that character i'm
fluent in that character
in a way that you're rarely fluent with
other people other than those
really close to you a spouse or a child
or a parent or a sister or brother
so
i believe
that you're right when you say that if
you've spent that amount of time doing
that where that's your job
the observation of the human condition
and the sort of interpretation of the
human condition
imbuing characters on tv with those
traits and those observations and that
kind of stuff and you have a secondary
interest even a casual one in
a humanistic discipline like philosophy
or
you know could be anything it could be
music or
academia or whatever
that you're not necessarily a
professional but you at least are
qualified i think you're qualified to
talk about the subject in some long-form
way now that doesn't mean that i want to
go on live tv and have a debate
with a with a professional philosopher
about who knows more
like
i don't want to i don't i think i would
be in over my head
to teach a class like i don't think i'm
qualified to teach a class
but to the extent that you're talking
about just qualification based on
just time spent thinking about something
i then i then i think i agree with you
because i have spent a lot of time
thinking about it and mulling it all
over
while also making it
digestible
and entertaining enough that people will
actually
ingest and think about what the hell
you're trying to convey right i mean
that's as you mentioned yeah it's like
if you go to any
campus bookstore and pick up the
required texts from like
philosophy
101 or
201 or 102 or whatever it might be i
mean good luck i mean if you want to get
like a million people to read those
books like yeah best of luck that's
going to be a really hard task
yeah and that's literally that's the
reason i wanted to write it it's that
the exact thing that you're pointing out
which is like i think there's a
tremendous amount
to be gained
from engaging with the basic ideas that
a lot of these philosophers
put out there and not not the real deep
intense you know philosophy grad school
level philosophy stuff just the basics
like the very very basic theories
are really valuable and can be really
helpful
but
in many cases even engaging with the
basic ideas
is really hard and it's their tech the
primary texts are not i would say
strictly speaking enjoyable to read like
they're just not that fun like pick up
critique of pure reason flip through a
couple pages and tell me how psyched you
are to polish it off in your free time
on the beach like it's forget it like
you'll never
you'll the average person even the way
above average person who's more
interested in philosophy than the
average person is not going to read
critique of pure reason on ashay's
lounge by the pool
on his or her summer vacation so that's
exactly the impetus really to write the
book was like if i can just relay
the nuts and bolts of the stuff as i
understand them and as some of my
professional philosopher friends have
helped me understand them
i think there's real potential value for
people in terms of how it can improve
their lives
the basics are the basics for a reason
in the sense that
you know michael jordan would still
practice free throws right at his peak
right
because there are certain foundational
elements right they're sort of the the
irreduci i shouldn't say irreducible but
these sort of
foundational pieces that have incredible
utility and then you can get into like
the intellectual masturbation
stratospheric level where it's like okay
you want to like hang out with
wittgenstein and talk about like you
know logicians and like you know it
depends on what is is isn't it you know
and you're like oh come on like we don't
need 700 pages on that give me a i need
to go get some [ __ ] groceries and i
need to decide i think this is an
example you've given you know whether or
not i do do i take the grocery cart and
put it back or leave it where it is like
okay like that's something i need to
process today yes 100
if you could have drinks or dinner
with any philosopher alive or dead
just for
entertainment value because is there
anyone who who comes to mind
for entertainment value so that's a
different entertainment no no you know
you know let me redact that
doesn't have to be for entertainment
value
i'll leave it i'll leave it broader than
that just
drinks or dinner you can choose one or
two okay a lot of philosophers
lives are sort of unknown right like no
one knows what really what like
aristotle was like as a guy
so some of them i have to like eliminate
just for that reason the name that comes
to mind is jeremy bentham who was an
18th century
english philosopher who is essentially
the guy who invented what's called
utilitarianism
which was very much in favor for a while
then completely fell out of favor and
recently has come back into favor in
academic circles
utilitarianism essentially is do more
good than bad that's how you're an
ethical person if the things you do
create more good or happiness or
pleasure than they do pain or suffering
or unhappiness the reason i would want
to have drinks with him though
is because he was also a true weirdo
like a truly weird guy
who when he died
he told his friend that he wanted his
body to essentially be preserved
and his head to be specifically
preserved and his skeleton to be
preserved and he wanted to be put on
display
at this university in london
he didn't found this university but he
was a sort of spiritual founder of it so
we said basically stuff me like a
scarecrow
and preserve my head
and put me on display so that as
students for the next hundred thousand
years walk into this university i will
greet them as they walk in so they tried
to preserve his head and it didn't work
in his head it was like disgusting
failure and was miserable so they they
created a wax head and they put on a
skeleton and they dressed him in one of
his old suits and he's still there you
can go see him
in his like wax head and skeleton and
his suit are still at this university
and he was just a sort of oddball
eccentric guy
who seems like and in his writing some
of which is
you know impenetrable
in the way that a lot of 18th century
writing now seems impenetrable but some
of it is really fun to read and he wrote
little fun poems sometimes little jaunty
rhyming poems about his philosophy and
and he was like uh it was a goofball he
was a weird guy and i feel like he would
be
very fun to like drink brandy with at
some at some like dark wood paneled club
in england somewhere
i mean there's a lot of philosophers
that it sounds like it would be fun
to eat or drink with but like some of
them
like i'll bet nietzsche would be fun to
have a meal with but also
he kind of accidentally helped create
the nazis and so it would be hard not to
bring that up over over your chicken pie
yard or whatever you're eating like a
lot of the philosophers in the book and
a lot of philosophers in general like a
lot of people from the last 400 years
are now problematic for a number of
different ways and
i don't know of offhand i'm sure that
bentham
bentham also argued for
a lot of things that not a lot of people
argued for back then like he was a i
would say a proto-feminist and a
a big sort of equal rights guy he was an
animal rights advocate like
he seems unbalanced from what i know of
him which again is not super deep but he
seems on balance to be less
potentially
problematic than a lot of the people
that you might choose for this dinner
you're imagining
yeah you know i wonder how problematic
we will be in
50 100 years probably very
but
let me ask you then if you could have
the
call a friend or siri feature
for two philosophers another way to
approach this question would be
if you could pick one or two
to just rely upon
instructionally
and this is individual to you right are
there two who you particularly identify
with as finding tremendously helpful to
you in whatever sense that translates
yeah aristotle's the first one that
comes to mind because aristotle's whole
thing aristotle created what is now
called virtue ethics and his
he didn't try to write a rule book right
he didn't say
do this don't do that this is okay this
is not okay
what he says is
there's a number of things
qualities
in a person personality traits call them
what you will
and that matter and those things are you
know courage and generosity and
magnanimity and things like that and his
goal was find the exact right amount of
all those qualities he called them
virtues and he said if you can nail that
sort of like dead solid midpoint of all
of these
qualities that's what a good person is
right so it's important that you be
courageous
but if you're too courageous you will be
rash his example is a soldier storming
over a hill and trying to take on an
entire army by himself and just getting
shot if you're not courageous enough
you'll abandon your
at the first sign of trouble you'll
abandon your unit and flee in the other
direction and then that's not good
either so the key is like be courageous
enough to do your job but not so
courageous that you act rashly so
that process
i find the most
forgiving of human foibles and
weirdnesses
and the most sort of humanistic of all
of the theories i find it to be the most
inviting
it's the most forgiving i think of the
mistakes that we are bound to make as
people
because you're gonna screw up he knows
you're gonna screw up you're gonna be
too
too magnanimous or not courageous enough
or too generous or whatever and he sort
of says like that's okay like you're
gonna blow it just check in
like do an accounting of what you've
done and then adjust and keep aiming
towards that dead solid middle perfect
spot right
so
i find him to be the most friendly i
guess is a word for it right he's like
the friendliest philosopher because he
doesn't like kant basically says if you
screw up you're dead to me like i won't
even look at you if you make a mistake
right he's just very very sticklery and
aristotle isn't like that he's sort of
like hey life is hard it's complicated
and it's weird and we're all going to
make mistakes and like the key isn't
whether you made a mistake the key is
what do you do now like if you've
registered that you've been too much of
this or not enough of that
next time aim get a little better and
that is just very
lovely to me
i find that philosophy to be the most
inviting so he is definitely one of the
two i have on speed dial if i can
he also by the way
granted he lived 2400 years ago but he
thought slavery was totally fine like he
has a lot of aristotle writing that's
like a defense of slavery and you're
like oh come on dude like
come on don't blow this for me i was so
into you and now you're talking about
how great it is to have slaves but the
other one
would be william james so william james
much more recent
lived in the late 19th century early
20th century
his theory is called pragmatism i also
find pragmatism incredibly inviting
he didn't really invent it but he kind
of developed it and
pragmatism basically says the only thing
that matters is what's true right like
if something is true then we can rely on
it and we can use it and pragmatism will
use any means necessary to get at a fact
a truth something that we can rely on
and hold in our hands and know
that it's real so he doesn't say you
have to be a utilitarian or you have to
be
a religious dogmatist or you have to be
a kanti and he doesn't care what method
you use as long as you
get to some kind of truth or fact and
then base your decision on that truth or
fact and that there's something just
very lovely i describe it in the book as
the jambalaya of philosophy right it's
like throw everything into the pot
everything we've got use whatever we can
like it doesn't he doesn't care what
theory you use or how you arrive at the
truth as long as what you're arriving at
is the truth and so
i really like that approach because in a
in a modern world i mean for him the
modern world was like you know 1896 or
whatever for us the modern world is for
2022 things have already gotten so much
more complicated than they were 100
years ago but he was sort of looking
around at an increasingly
complex world and saying we don't have
time to only use one theory here we got
to use all of them we got to use
everything we have every tool in our
tool belt we should be able to use
at any moment in order to arrive at
something that we can agree upon is true
and so
i feel like on my speed dial i've got
aristotle to just like rub my back and
tell me everything's gonna be okay and
then
keep trying man keep going like putting
putting one of those silver marathon
blankets around me when the world is too
wearying and then i've got william james
to be the guy who's like all right let's
walk through what we know let's get to
some kind of fundamental truth that we
can rely on and i feel like those two
guys would work well in concert with
each other
i have a lot of reading to do i like i'm
looking forward to my my first edition
of how to be perfect i think
i need a plastic jacket and an
inscription possibly got to get your
mylar man you got to protect that dust
jacket that's where all the value is you
know i do know mylar because i still
have every comic book i collected as a
kid which is several thousand comic
books all mylar bagged and backed
not that i've done much with them
they've just they've really just sat
there but what is the crown jewel of
your collection what's that what's the
if you could only say five comic books
what are they
oh you know i'm not a comic book guy so
this is all new to me i don't know
anything about comics what do we got
keep in mind i was working as a busboy
on long island and buying what i could
with
very meager funds so i don't have any
particularly valuable comics i don't
think i would probably
save
the comics
that introduced me to specific
characters and and specific artists so a
lot of jim lee
basically resurrecting the x-men
i would save
mcfarland i would
probably grab some punisher war journal
long story
things that made some indelible mark
on my childhood which is the same reason
i still have all of my dungeons and
dragons i have my modules i have
fiendfolio
dungeons and dragons had a formative
impact
on my
childhood and
for those wondering grey elf was my
particular race uh preferred race
dro elves or drow i'm not sure how you
pronounce it uh we're interesting to me
chaotic good also
preferred but i'm getting into the weeds
uh a bit so
i completely lost track of where i was
but that's nothing new you know we're
not really deviating from philosophy
because philosophy is everywhere even if
you don't recognize it right and if you
decide not to care about philosophy well
that's part of your philosophy
correct deciding not to care so it's
sort of inevitable not to i feel like
all all roads lead back to david foster
wallace but the uh
you know the the commencement speech but
what is it this is water or this is
water i can't recall yeah just so people
aren't lost on the reference i think he
begins with this
joke slash parable of two young
fish swimming along and they pass an
older fish
and the older fish says how's the water
boys something like that and the younger
fish continue on and then they go what
the hell is water right right
excellent commencement speech actually
ties into a lot of what we're talking
about
but
when we when we look at your bio
because you're talking about aristotle
and the marathon blanket and when life
gets tough for when you're feeling
particularly weary when we look at your
bio that i read in the introduction
i mean it just seems like step up to the
plate home run home run home run just
batting a thousand right that's that's
maybe the impression because that's what
buyers are intended to do they don't
list the mistakes and the failures do
you have any
favorite
failures by which i mean
a mistake a failure whether it was
viewed that way by
you or by other people that you learned
a lot from that was particularly
valuable that set you up in some
unexpected way for a success later
anything
dude do any
failures come to mind however you might
define that
uh i mean i've never failed once
so no that's good because i was i was
kind of trapping you the how to be
perfect title
a book with such a title cannot be
written by a charlatan
yeah so my failures that are valuable
are
sort of smaller scale than you i think
would think there have certainly been
projects i've developed
pilots i've made show ideas i've had
that never wet anywhere like they you go
along the process you're making them you
write the script they say no thank you
you make the pilot they look at the
pilot they say no we're not making this
like that kind of failure is it very
common very typical
i don't think
that they have taught me as much as some
i guess what you would call smaller
scale failures so going back to snl for
a second so here's how snl works
on the monday and tuesday of every week
you
sit around your office and you goof
around and you write sketches
and you usually the way it usually goes
is you stay up tuesday night until like
nine in the morning you stay up all
night and you write all night and then
on wednesday there's a read-through the
host comes in and lauren comes in the
cast sits around a giant table and the
crew piles into this room and you read
they read through you know 45 or 50
sketches over four hours
and just one after another boom boom
boom boom boom and then there's a
meeting afterwards and lauren and the
head writers and producers and the hosts
all kind of pick here are the dozen
sketches we're going to do this week
so there's a specific kind of failure at
snl
that is so painful and visceral
that
i still and this is not an exaggeration
it's not i'm not saying this for a fact
i still have occasional nightmares about
this particular failure okay
the particular failure is it's the third
hour of the read through
your sketch is number 28 in the rundown
they start lauren reads the title of the
sketch here this title here okay next
sketch is uh you know caveman olympics
by mike shore
and the
people start reading the sketch and then
whatever the joke of the sketches is
sort of sprung the first joke comes up
and it dies like no one laughs even a
tiny bit
and what you know
is that there's nine more pages
on that joke premise coming
and
the first one didn't work and all you
have is nine more pages of it and
what happens next is the sketch is
dutifully read by the cast and the host
and the only sound in the room
is the sound of like a hundred and ten
people
turning pages in a in a sheaf of stapled
stable paper
that's the only sound it's just the like
[Applause]
over and over again
and
it is like if you've ever wondered
whether flop sweat is real
i
actively flop sweat
flop sweated
so many times in those moments where i
was like i want to die i want to i want
to get up and run out of the room
screaming
because this is so painful it's all of
these funny people in my era it was like
you know will ferrell and molly shannon
and tracy morgan and tina fey and jimmy
fallon and
all these the funniest people in the
world and all of your peers all of the
writers who were also the funniest
people in the world and you cannot make
one of them laugh for one tenth of one
second
and
as painful as that is and i experienced
it so many times
as painful as that is what happens is if
you can survive it
you get to the other side of it and
nothing bothers you like there's
literally
no
kind of institutional failure that can
phase you anymore i mean that doesn't
mean you don't get upset when things
don't work out of course you do it
doesn't mean you don't get sad or
depressed or need someone to talk to or
rely on or you don't need aristotle to
wrap a metallic blanket around your
shoulders when things don't go your way
of course you do
but in the creative world
that pain that failure that weekly
sometimes failure
just absolutely thickened my skin
to such a wonderful degree that i just
realized like this doesn't matter this
is sketch comedy this is all
goofing around this is silliness it's
not
life or death it's not the stakes of
this are not the end of the world the
stakes of this are like did your sketch
work this week
and that
really evens you out a little bit
because then the flip side of that coin
is you write a sketch and it kills and
it gets solid laughs all the way through
and then it gets produced and you mount
it and it works on the stage it works in
dress rehearsal works in rehearsal works
in dress rehearsal it goes on the live
show it works on the live show you made
the people in the studio laugh maybe
even in a rare case in my at least for
me
the sketch kind of gets like goes a
little viral you know like you know you
see it pop up on the internet and people
remember it fondly
when that happens
a thing you don't think is
i've nailed this like i'm good man i
know how to do this job i'm a rock star
i've got this down like because you know
that your next like four and a half
minutes of brutal silent
paper shuffling failure
is one week away it's gonna happen next
week and so
it just keeps you
in this range of
of reasonable reaction to the world that
is pretty narrow and that you don't get
a big head
your successes don't make you into a
monster and your failures don't make you
into a like a depressive person or a
miserable person who complains and yells
and screams and lashes out of people
because
it just is a matter of it's a matter of
course in your life and i really think
that that kind of failure especially at
a young age for me was so valuable and i
i love it i love that failure i love
thinking about it
and
keeping it like close to my soul because
i really think
if you've experienced that failure
you cannot become a monster and that's
why
not all but the vast majority of people
i know
who went through snl
are really nice people they're just nice
and good and kind and they have a level
head and i think it's because we just
got all
beaten up and we we ate that failure we
shoved that failure down our throats
over and over and over again and it just
taught us that like
you can't ever
let yourself think too much of yourself
because you just have that institutional
memory of failure you know oh that
retelling just it makes my palms sweat
just thinking about it me too man so
bad so
bad
and what a gift also right it is the
greatest gift over and over again yeah
i'm telling you just taught that you
cannot take yourself too seriously right
because god the consequences of that
will be just so severe
yeah and it's it's not just that you
can't take yourself too seriously it's
that you are not
god's gift to the world and you know i
saw
the greatest comedians of our generation
bomb week after week after week i saw
will ferrell take huge swings and bomb i
saw tina fey take huge swings and bomb
and granted their successes were much
more frequent than mine or really
anyone's like their
tina fey's batting average on that show
in the six years i was there was the
highest of anyone's and she probably hit
you know
400 which is great for a baseball player
and incredible for an snl sketch writer
but for most people if you failed at
your job 60 of the time
you would be crushed but because of the
nature of the job and because it's
constantly reminding you like this is an
absurd way to make a living right like
this is ridiculous
you're hanging out with your friends in
an office and making jokes all day like
you can't
ever get to a point where you get too
worked up or too angry or too upset
about things because it's absurd and you
learn to take
the successes with a grain of salt and
the failures with a grain of salt and i
really believe
that that failure for me at least was a
tremendous gift and i'm so so grateful
for it
i'm glad i asked that question
um
not that i'm taking credit for the
answer i can't take credit for the
answer but
let me just ask a few more
questions i i could go for hours but
let me ask a question that is very often
a question that leads to a dead end uh
so i will take the blame for that if
that's the case
but here goes nothing
so if you could put anything on a
billboard metaphorically speaking
non-commercial
to get a message out to
billions of people let's all assume they
speak
english it doesn't have to be
a quote it could be a question it could
be an image it could be anything at all
is there anything that comes to mind
that you might put on such a billboard
this is what i think i would say and
this goes back to a thing i wrote about
in the book the last chapter of the book
is about apologizing
and
what i say in the book is
this isn't really ethics you know it's
not like ethic apologizing isn't an
ethical question because ethics has much
more to do with whatever it is that you
did that made you have to apologize
right whatever you do whatever you blew
it that was probably an ethical question
or in many cases was so apologizing
isn't really ethics but i think it's
sort of ethics adjacent i think it's
like it's like i describe it as an exit
interview after you've made an ethical
decision that blew up in your face now
here's your exit interview why did you
do it like what have you learned like
try to heal the wound a little bit of
whatever the action was that caused this
little problem
and
what's interesting about apologizing i
think is
that everyone is bad at it and i will
absolutely include myself in this like
everyone no one wants to do it
everybody flinches and and and holds
back when you know you should apologize
to someone for something you never want
to do it you put it off you
procrastinate you have a conversation
with the person you should apologize to
and you just don't apologize to them and
you're like god dammit why can't i just
apologize to this person
it's a really hard thing for people to
do because it's icky it's like you feel
shame and your face flushes and you get
hot and you start sweating and
and it's just it's a hard thing to do
but i also think that it's really
important and it's a thing that in my
life i have tried
i've worked on
really really hard
to get better at it to become a person
who
recognizes when i've made mistakes and
apologizes for them not
eight months later or
you know ten years later but in the
moment like in the moment
i really try to be a person who
who says oh no
i blew this and i i made a mistake and i
should immediately apologize and try to
like heal this little wound
i don't think i'm succeeding at least
100 or even 50 at being that person but
i think i'm better than i used to be
and it's not easy
and i'm very very
understanding of people who have a hard
time doing it there's another version of
a bad apology that we see all the time
in the public sphere which is when
people say
you know i'm sorry if you were offended
or something like that which is not
that's not an apology man that's not
apology that's you saying i did nothing
wrong and you're stupid enough to think
that i did something wrong so i'm sorry
you're so stupid that's what that is
yeah
so there's a lot of bad apologies
there's a lot of procrastinating there's
a lot of delayed apologies
this is all a long-winded way of saying
that i think if i could put up this
imaginary billboard or push notification
or whatever i think i would just say
the message would be say you're sorry
and i would trust that all
five billion people who read it
would think like how did you know that i
have someone i should apologize to
because we all do
everybody's got something to apologize
for to someone and
i don't think that all five billion
people would apologize for whatever they
were should apologize for but i'll bet
that some people
if they got a message from the
netherworld that said hey say you're
sorry
they would go yeah you're right i should
call jim and apologize for that thing
that i did to him last week or whatever
that would be maybe the greatest chance
of mass success on a utilitarian scale
that i could probably achieve
i'm now imagining in my mind you know
driving down the highway and there's
actually a sequence of billboards and
the first one says say you're sorry
and then the next one says i know it
sucks but it's important
[Applause]
right
and the next one says you still haven't
done it come on man you know you gotta
do it
[Laughter]
todd may so you spoke to
a gazillion different
you spoke to slash harassed
slash
pulled into conversation many different
philosophers many different professors
professor todd may of clemson
ended up as i understand it being an
advisor of sorts to
the good place
also was involved in the book
what makes
todd special why todd
the first thing that makes him special
is
that
we were working on the good place in
season two
and
season two spoiler alert stop listening
for a second if you haven't seen the
show yet
season two involves a
michael ted danson's character is a
immortal
being from the afterlife who is trying
to learn
essentially human philosophy right and
we had this moment where we were like
well
how in the world is an immortal alien
whatever he is gonna give a crap about
human philosophy right like he's eternal
he's an eternal being why would he care
about whether you you know correctly
interacted with a human being in some
small moment
so we went looking we were like i wonder
if anyone's ever written about the
morality of
immortality like what happens if you're
immortal does morality matter and turns
out someone did write about that it's
todd may and he wrote a book called
death a great book it's very short it's
like maybe a hundred pages and easily
readable
and he talks about how
like mortality
gives sort of shape and definition to
our lives because we know that
everything ends
and morality is what helps us make sense
of those lives while we're living them
and if you're immortal then none of this
matters like if you're immortal
whatever you you make a mistake big deal
you're going to live for
infinite number of years like
the memory of your crummy mistake will
fade over time and it won't matter
anymore right
so he happened to have written this book
that was about the exact thing that we
needed to learn about at that time so i
read the book
and then i was like god this is a great
book this guy could really help us i
reached out to him i had a zoom meeting
with him to talk about the book and i
found him to be the most lovely
congenial
intelligent friendly
conversational person i had ever met
certainly within the realm of academia
but also maybe in life like he's just a
lovely person
and i said
would you ever want to come into our
writer's room and just like talk to us
about philosophy and he was like sure so
he popped into our room we did a zoom
meeting with him
and then when he was he came to la once
and he came in and talked to us about a
bunch of stuff that we didn't understand
and he just became this kind of like
it was like a an emergency uh break
break in case of emergency like we would
if we had a question about philosophy we
would smash the glass pick up a red
phone it would be connected directly to
todd may and we would say please explain
existentialism and he would explain it
to us and we say thank you we would hang
up and go back to writing the script and
so he just became that guy
he and a woman in pamela hironomy who
taught at ucla became our two go-to
advisors and
when i had to write the book or i wanted
to write the book at the end of the show
i had just had such a lovely time
working with him
that i said like i think i need someone
who really knows his or her stuff to
sort of sit next to me and look over my
shoulder and make sure i don't really
blow it
and so that's the role he played he he
was the guy who made sure that when i
talked about philosophers and what they
said that i wasn't getting it terribly
wrong
and then would also explain to me a
bunch of stuff i didn't understand so
he it was just a happy coincidence that
he happened to have written about the
exact thing that we needed to know about
at that moment and then he just sort of
joined the team and and helped us out
for the rest of the time the show was on
the air
just so i make sure i'm getting this
right the other name you mentioned is
pamela hironomy so that would be tyrone
hieronomy
as a philosophy professor that is pretty
great right
incredible it's a wonderful name yeah i
know
that's really outstanding
well
this has been a a lovely and uh much
longer than expected conversation and i
really appreciate you being so
generous and patient
with my never-ending stream of
questions the book i i'm very excited
about this
how to be perfect subtitle the correct
answer to every moral question by
michael shurer s-c-h-u-r-a-k-a
ken tremendous on twitter
and
elsewhere
is there anything else that you would
like to
say any closing comments
complaints requests to the audience
anything at all that you'd like to add
before we wrap up
i guess i would only say that
whether it's it's my book or
another book
and there are plenty of them
that i think deal with this topic
well and and conversationally
i would urge you all to
do a bit of your own educational reading
on the subject of ethics i think that
ethics is
i would so much rather
that my kids take classes in ethics
in high school than advanced math
or or biochemistry like uh and nothing
against those subjects but i think that
the two subjects that are woefully
undertaught
in this country
and that are really the foundational
underpinnings of everything that i think
is important for the continuation of
society are ethics and civics i think
understanding the way governments work
and understanding the way that ethics
work and the way that we treat each
other
are vitally important and i hope that
whether it's from my book or from some
other
some other survey or some other set of
of articles or anything
i really believe that people could
greatly benefit from just the basic
understanding of what these people said
about ethics how they work
the different theories that are out
there
applying them to your own lives i know
that i have gotten a tremendous amount
of
happiness and satisfaction from just
even when i do the wrong thing which is
frequent
i take a tremendous amount of pleasure
from wrestling with the questions
and from
at least having some kind of scaffolding
or
structure that i can go to and think
about and use to examine the problems
that i face in my life so i just
recommend ethics as a as a life
improvement strategy
i think they're really interesting and
really valuable and i encourage everyone
to just poke around even if it's
literally reading a wikipedia page or
something
it really can i think be of great
benefit to just about everyone on earth
hear hear i
fully agree with that and i'm going to
so that that last question was a false
summit i apologize
i realized that i need to mention or ask
you to mention something because i don't
think you're going to mention it without
some prompting what happens to the
proceeds from this book uh
yes so
when i wanted to write this book i had
two thoughts back to back one of them
was that sounds really hard and really
fun and i think the fact that it sounds
really hard and fun means i ought to do
it
and the second thought was it would be
really weird to personally profit from a
book about ethics and being a better
person
so
i
am donating every single cent that i
make from the book from
anything involved in the book from
foreign sales of the book the advance
the royalties the
any speaking honorarium
that comes from the book
it's all being donated 100 of it to
charity to one of five charities
potentially more down the line if if um
todd and i todd is in on this too
i forced todd to take a small payment
for his professional time but he is also
joining me and donating the majority of
what he makes as well
so the first payment went to the irc
which is a wonderful charity
that
you can find at rescue.org that helps
people in need all over the world we're
donating one-fifth of it to the
rainforest trust which buys and
preserves rainforest land we've got
other charities lined up in the worlds
of social justice and
and legal justice and
world central kitchen is the was the
second one i think we donated to so
anyway we're donating i'm donating every
single dollar i ever make from this to
charities so that's another good reason
to buy it is you know that
you're also contributing to
to some good cause somewhere in the
world
i love everything about this you know
which is premature because i haven't
read the book but i i plan on it
but uh i have really enjoyed this
conversation and i really appreciate you
taking so much time i know you have many
options
for what you may do with your time and
this has just been great i really
encourage people to check out the book
how to be perfect the correct answer to
every moral question
if it only delivers 20
even 20 20 25 percent just think about
think about how better
[Laughter]
and
for everybody listening we will have
links to everything including the book
and anything else that we've mentioned
we didn't even get to
the specific episodes of tv shows that
you re-watch like the constant from lost
or the fly from breaking bad maybe
another conversation sure but i find you
to be
very fascinating very engaging and a
very good teacher just from this
conversation which makes me very
optimistic about this book
which is also reflected in the writing
from the good place and elsewhere so i'm
i'm very very optimistic about this
and uh for those people listening you
can find all the links and resources at
the show notes at tim dot blog podcast
as per usual and until next time
just say you're sorry god damn it just
get around to it
and thank you for tuning in
you